we continue our countdown to the top 30
story lines for 2019 and we're up to
number seven and this one deals with the
defending NFC North champions a Bears
franchise that really hasn't done much
in recent years sporadically we see a
playoff appearance but we don't see that
sustained year in and year out success
that we would expect from one of the
signature franchises in the National
Football League well now they've got the
reigning coach of the year in Matt naggy
and they have a promising young
quarterback in Mitchell true Biscay who
entering his third season is in his
second season with the Matt naggy
offense and the real question for the
Bears yeah I know Vic Fangio is gone as
defensive coordinator but they still
have the talent there and Chuck Pagano
has been in the past a very good
defensive tactician this is about
Mitchell true Biscay lifting the Bears
to the next level can he do it there are
a lot of people out there a surprising
number of people who don't believe in
Mitchell true Biscay remember not that
long ago there was a sports book in Las
Vegas that had opening odds for true
Biscay winning the NFL MVP award at 200
to 1 and it was almost instantly bet
down to 50 to 1 look true Biscay could
end up being the NFL MVP because it's a
quarterback award that is given to the
best teams quarterback if that
quarterback has had a very strong year
and typically the best team in the NFL
has a quarterback who is playing at a
very high level and it could be true
Biscay he can pass and he can run think
back to that Sunday night game last year
against the Vikings where he was running
circles around the Vikings defenders and
making it easier for the Bears to
ultimately out score the Vikings in that
high-profile primetime game true Biscay
if he can elevate to a new level
in his game play he can take that team
to another level and this is a team of
franchise and it sounds cliche because
we've been saying it for so long
they haven't had a franchise quarterback
since Sid Luckman Jay Cutler is the
closest thing they've had and what did
Jay Cutler ever do he took the Bears to
one playoff appearance during his time
with the team and yes he piled up a lot
of numbers but not nearly enough wins
true Biscay could have both the numbers
and the wins and we look at what the
Bears did last year this is their
opportunity to do something that the
Bears have rarely ever done at least
in the Super Bowl era which is put
together multiple two three four years
of great contending teams we saw it in
the 80s but they never really fulfilled
the potential that we we believe they
had based upon the 1985 Bears didn't go
back to another Super Bowl wasn't where
they weren't back to another Super Bowl
until more than a decade ago against the
cults now is their opportunity to begin
to build something that will make them a
team that is a presumed playoff
contender every year a team that can get
to the Super Bowl a team that can win
the Super Bowl and it all comes down to
whether or not their young quarterback
from North Carolina the guy who was the
surprise number two overall pick the guy
who was selected before both Patrick
homes and deshaun Watson can true Biscay
push this team to the next level it's
going to be one of the biggest stories
for the 2019 season
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports